how's it going everybody it's Warren
welcome back to the channel where we
talk about Marvel and of course the MCU
today we got to talk about spider-man 3
and future spider-man films venom 2 and
Morbius the groundwork has been laid for
the spider-verse between the Marvel
Cinematic Universe and the Sony
spider-verse and it's actually going to
be a lot different and a lot bigger than
we thought it was going to be originally
of course it all started with the
Morbius trailer we saw a picture of
spider-man that said murderer over and
then we saw vulture confirming that
characters from spider-man from the
Marvel Cinematic Universe are crossing
over to Sony spider-verse and now we
have official confirmation that venom is
going to be referenced in Morpheus so
the groundwork has been laid for a venom
spider-man crossover and eventually the
sinister six as well and fortunately for
us we are hearing that spider-man is
going to be a part of the MCU for much
longer than just one solo film and then
a crossover film it appears that Marvel
and Sony have established a very good
relationship and have big plans to
continue to share spider-man in the
Marvel Cinematic Universe and Sony
spider-verse
so it looks like Spidey is here to stay
for a very long time which is awesome
news so let's dive into this report if
you're new be sure to subscribe so you
can stay up to date on all the Marvel
related news also so you can enter my
giveaway for a chance to win an Xbox one
or ps4 picking a winner at 550,000
subscribers so we know that after the
spider-man scare between Sony and Marvel
Sony and Marvel struck up a new deal for
spider-man to remain in the MCU and
rumor has it right now that the deal
does include a major crossover with
venom this comes as little to no
surprise as Sony originally wanted Tom
Holland spider-man in the first venom
film however Marvel didn't want that
because they didn't want fans to confuse
the Marvel Cinematic Universe with the
spider verse which is completely
understandable however the new deal that
Marvel and Sony seemingly made was for
spider-man 3 to wrap up Peter Parker's
high school years we will then continue
on with Peter Parker's story during his
college years and this is apparently
where we are going to see the Venom
symbiote bond with Peter Parker
spider-man and this will be built up
over time through various different
movies from Sony including Morbius venom
to and most like
venom three before we see spider-man
four with these movies having major
references to the MCU version of
spider-man
and then ultimately and finally going on
to introduce the sinister six with the
Sony movies in the meantime also
referencing other characters in the
sinister six as well and this has just
recently been confirmed as we have a
photo from the set of Morbius as you can
see from this photo we have a little
note to venom here it seems like there's
going to be several references to other
characters with graffiti in Morbius when
we saw the spider-man photo in the
Morbius trailer spray-painted over it in
graffiti it said murderer connecting the
Marvel Cinematic Universe spider-man to
Morbius and now it appears the same
thing that's going to happen with venom
a little picture spray-painted of venom
with the word venom below so slowly but
surely the universe is all starting to
connect and it appears that they are
going to build the sinister six up much
like they did the Avengers introduced
each character individually give them a
little bit of a story and then have them
all come together for one common cause
which of course will be spider-man again
this is really good news for spider-man
in the MCU because it appears that Sony
is letting Marvel wrap up what they
started in the MCU and then the two of
them are going to continue working
together having spider-man like Kevin
Feige said be the only character that
can go between the two different
universes and it seems like venom could
be added to that character list and make
an appearance in the next spider-man
after spider-man 3 and of course in
spider-man 3 we will most likely see a
character from the sinister six be
introduced Kraven the hunter so we'll
have a great ending to the trilogy and
then a great start to the next one
that's going to take place in both the
Sony universe and the Marvel Cinematic
Universe so let me know what you think
about these new reports if they end up
becoming true is this a route that you
would like to see spider-man go down hit
me with your thoughts in the comments
below don't forget to give this video a
like and subscribe to stay up-to-date on
all Marvel content and to enter my
giveaway for a chance to win an Xbox one
or ps4 for live updates follow me on
Twitter and as always thank you all so
much for watching woof woof
you